so notice the son of man is the one that
came down from heaven
but john is the one that is saying here
that the one who comes from above is
above all but he says it's the
bridegroom
the son of man is the bridegroom awesome
it's kind of nice to know that your
judge is also the one who wants to marry
you right
right right that's a good point hey
everybody welcome to led live did you
know that the book of revelation
is actually a wedding story find out on
this episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness welcome to
our show everyone and today's topic
is a topic that should hopefully make
everybody smile
a topic of love and weddings
and i don't know if there's anybody that
actually doesn't like
love have you ever met somebody that
doesn't like love i love them
and at this time of the year you know
february is obviously
um valentine's time and so people are
naturally more open to
the topic of love if you would but i'm
kind of excited about today's topic
because
we have a guest today scott burgess
thank you for coming on
and tell us a little bit about what you
actually do right now currently
okay i teach at washte hills college in
amity arkansas
i teach a number of courses today i'm
going to focus
on on some material from daniel in
revelation but i also teach hebrew and
greek
public speaking i teach how to give
bible studies one-on-one
nice so it's not every day that we get
somebody who is
extremely detailed in this particular
topic
and i'm excited because scott's actually
written a book on
the connections of the wedding and our
parallels to christianity as you're
going to see
today it's a really a cool topic
i mean when i first heard these messages
i remember thinking like wow i've never
even
made those connections in my mind but
hopefully after today
you guys will begin to see every wedding
differently and then also you'll be able
to begin to have
an appreciation for the book of
revelation and to see the love story
that it's actually
um really all about yes so um
i'm excited let's jump into this today
we're gonna
consider a question here on just
revelation chapter one
the time is at hand that's a quotation
from the third verse
the question is what time
[Music]
and so we look at our first verse here
revelation one verse 3
blessed is he that readeth and they that
hear the words of this prophecy
and keep those things which are written
therein for the time is at hand
so there's our time right there at the
opening but
if you're like me i wondered well what
time
yeah it's interesting that the book of
revelation starts with that blessed are
they that read this book
because a lot of people shy away from it
they think it's confusing sometimes
scary these people actually said yeah
it's at the end of the book for a reason
the bible so let me stick to the
beginning parts but that's wonderful
that it intentionally started that way
how many other books do you read and say
i'm not going to read the ending
yeah exactly how the whole thing wraps
up yeah i'm watching a movie
10 minutes before the end i'm just going
to shut it off yeah it is the
culmination of the whole bible coming
together in the end of time i mean
that's
that's what i hear when i see the time
is at hand is sort of this whole thing
that we've all been laboring for
throughout history how does this thing
end how does it play out let's see when
jesus wins
that's right and i know some of you
pastors
that they encouraged not to read that
book yeah you won't understand because
you understand prophetic and yeah
or something like that
it's not relevant to the christian
church because we're not even going to
be here so don't don't even mind well
there you go wow you guys remember those
paintings from the 80s
that you would stare at and if you like
made your eyes do like a certain
thing that all of a sudden you could see
like the stereograms
stereogram is that what it's called yeah
yeah i think that's more the technical
name but there's another name for you
magic eye
okay so so but there's something that
you have to do with your eyes to be able
to see that right
i think that the book of revelation is
like that when you understand
how to look at it then it then it's like
whoa there's this crazy image in
throughout here
and that's what this does for me and one
the good thing too is that
i mean it's pointless to say there's a
blessing for the one that reads unless
it can be understood
yeah and all the books of the bible they
meet right there in revelation
so if you want to understand it start
finding every place that it quotes from
and then it begins to make sense
that's awesome so let's take a look here
so what time is at hand
and it turns out revelation chapter 1
actually provides the hints
when you look at those it becomes
evident what time so let's look at our
first tent
in verse 5 it says that the book is from
jesus christ who is the faithful
witness okay so when you when you hear
witness what kinds of
um well pictures come to mind sharing
your faith with somebody
okay so you're thinking like a christian
sharing your faith okay
present when something happens okay i'd
be physically there
and then sometimes if it was uh maybe a
crime where would you say you observe
something's happening yeah confirms that
something happened
okay but maybe if you were in a
courtroom you might have to give
you know bear witness you have your
testimony okay so it is the language of
a courtroom
uh another hint in the 10th verse it
says i was in the spirit on the lord's
day
and heard behind me a great voice as of
a trumpet
and right there that actually has
something to do with it too there's the
trumpet announcing the time
but to understand this right where is
the first place in scripture
that you all recall reading about a
trumpet
i'm just gonna throw out there like
jericho i don't know if that's okay
that's early but it's act there's the
first instance is even before that
an actual trumpet in the old testament
that's right
i don't know think of the book of exodus
oh yeah yeah yeah
it
yeah yeah they use trumpets to move the
company yeah so what about when they
were coming before the mountain of god
that was our trumpet there we go
exodus 19 16. that's exactly right it
came to pass on the third day in the
morning
that there were thunders and lightnings
and a thick cloud up on the mount
and the voice of the trumpet exceeding
loud so that all the people that was in
the camp trembled
and this is when they're coming to get
the ten commandments notice they also
they call it a voice of a trumpet
voice of a trumpet here in revelation so
this is clearly what it's alluding to
right there
you imagine how loud that have to be it
was millions of people around that
mountain right right now the reason
that's important is because
that voice that trumpet-like voice
announcing
god's presence going to give the ten
commandments when you look at the end of
ecclesiastes it tells us that these
commandments
that this is going to be the basis of
the judgment it says god will bring
every work into judgment with every
secret thing
whether it be good or whether it be evil
but it says
keep his commandments so when we think
commandments
oh it takes us back to a judgment system
okay so now that should be kind of
enough right there those two kind of
suggest
what time is in view
that's right and you said the
commandments which takes you back to
that
voi that trumpet voice where the
commandments were given
[Music]
now if that's all that was to it or
about it some people might think well i
don't want to
i don't want to be looking at a judgment
scene that doesn't sound nice you know
and
nobody likes to be summoned to court
right but that's because we live in a
fallen world
but god's ways uh it's better
it turns out things start taking on a
brighter brighter tone when you look at
revelation 1 13.
it says that in the midst of the seven
candlesticks one like unto the son of
man
and so now our attention is focused on
son of man now who's the son of man
jesus jesus okay so our attention's on
jesus but it's interesting it doesn't
say that it's jesus it doesn't call him
the good shepherd
it doesn't column you know any of the
number of titles it calls on the son of
man right there
that in itself is a huge clue about what
the book is about
so we're going to explore what does that
expression tell us
well it turns out the first place that
that title is used is in daniel 7 13
and this is where daniel gets a vision
of the end time judgment and he sees
jesus come
as the son of man so
that title again is associated with
judgment right there
so the first phrase of the first use of
the phrase son of man in the bible
is in daniel right there do you have
that first does it is that gonna
throw you off can we hear it yeah daniel
7 13 daniel says i saw in the night
visions and behold
one like unto the son of man came with
the clouds of heaven
and came to the ancient of days and they
brought him near before him
wow and jesus referred to himself as the
son of man right
so and it's interesting that he did we
might think well he's sort of identified
with us or something
but when we see what the bible really
says about the son of man then we can
understand even more
just how important it was that he was
always referring himself as the son of
man
you know why did he use that title so
uh the context there is is the judgment
because a few verses earlier verses 9
and 10 it plainly says
daniel says i be held till the thrones
were cast down or set in place
the ancient of days did sit whose
garment was white as snow
and then if you drop down right here it
says the judgment was
set and the books were open so the son
of man is coming when the judgment opens
that's that's the setting right there um
notice here in verse 14 of revelation 1
it goes on it describes jesus it says
that his head and his
hairs were white like wool as white as
snow and his eyes were as a flame of
fire
that language is coming from the same
setting because jesus hair is described
the same as his father the ancient days
it's white
and it describes his eyes as a flame of
fire that expression was used in daniel
7 about god's throne
okay uh so yes the angel of davis was
presiding over the judgment there
that whole setting in daniel 7 is the
end time judgment notice this
in john chapter 5 it says here that
as the father has life in himself so has
he given to the son to have life in
himself and has given him authority to
execute judgment also because he's the
son of man
so though the father is on the throne
he's like presiding everything
he says okay i'm going to delegate to
you and you can
you can execute judgment so we have the
son of man is the judge
that fits in a courtroom setting but
it's still not necessarily
attractive you know we're thinking oh if
we have this idea that god's going to
throw the book at us as it were we might
think this sounds like really bad news
but the bible's about gloria's good news
so we need to understand what exactly is
the judge in the bible
and when we have that in place things
look a whole lot better here
so yes jesus is conducting the end time
judgment but let's consider something
else
why else is jesus called the son of man
there's something we haven't touched on
yet
and it makes all the difference was it
because he was prophesied to be the seed
that came to the woman
so he was the son that came that was the
promised son so it is
so to speak yes that is absolutely true
he came
as one of us and so he would be well
equipped to judges he knows what it's
like
to have these struggles and everything
yeah there's that there's that link in
the bible and i was reading it the other
day i think it's in luke
where it says that adam is the son of
god
you know and so of course adam had that
dominion if you will well he
gave it up so to speak right and so then
the dominion passes to satan and so
jesus comes back to
gain the dominion but he has to become
the son of
man you know he would be in man's place
in order to get that dominion back
he's going to pick up for adam veil
because adam filled with a test on diet
right there
and jesus when he begins his ministry
the devil has access to
tempt him for those 40 days and it
wasn't just on the 40th day the bible
says it was on all 40 days he's tempting
but he really hit him hard on the 40th
day
and of course he was victorious because
he never once sinned
so he knows what's like to be tempted
but he also knows what's to have victory
i know this is probably off topic but
there's got to be something with 40 days
right
the rains came down for 40 days 40
nights right
yeah i think when you actually get um
into like rehab for drug abuse isn't
there like a 40-day period that
once you get past that i don't know
in a biblical context though the
children of israel went through the
wilderness for 40 years
right much of jesus life is kind of
you know typifying and overcoming where
they
failed right but the the timeline is you
know
crunched if you will right so i don't
think it's random that on the 40th day
the devil came up to jesus and
really hit him hard with his full brunt
of it it's it's a it's a testing period
you know it was proving the children of
israel before they'd go into the
promised land
it was proving jesus so it says i'm
gonna if i can get you to fall in that
40th day it's all right
right but of course he miserably failed
right and jesus was victorious
but god destroyed also the earth the
first time for 40 days
it was raining for 40 days you know so
something i don't know if it's
purification but it sounded like
all evil was destroyed and something new
is coming but so it's going to take 40
days so
get rid of his stuff and then start
i don't know if you're gonna bring up
hebrews and i don't know verbatim
or the reference but in hebrews it says
we have a high priest
who has been tempted like we have or
something like that we're going to look
at that yes
and it fits in we're going to cover one
thing before that but then it all
it all just it gels yep
but we're going to look at the question
okay why else is jesus called the son of
man it does point to him as the judge
the one who's
who's um he's just perfect to judge but
there's something else
uh if you all have a bible here pull up
matthew 25 verse 13.
okay says watch
therefore for you know neither the day
nor the hour in which the son of man is
coming
okay now again if you understand him as
the judge you might think oh this could
really be bad because what if i happen
to be not watching that day
however this is the parable of the 10
virgins
so it's the first 13 verses there in
matthew 25 it says where to watch for
the son of man
however if you read verse 1 what does it
say there
then shall the kingdom of heaven be
likened to ten virgins
which took their lamps and went forth to
meet the bridegroom
aha it doesn't say the son of man but
it's evidently the same person right
and so the son of man is who they're
right oh
now we're getting this wedding picture
here
and this is where things take on a whole
new luster yeah it totally changes the
scene from
you know oh i got court tomorrow to i'm
gonna meet my spouse and
be betrothed to them like it's yeah
totally different
yeah hopefully you're not going to your
wedding with trembling thinking oh no
oh i'm going to see her i mean that's
crazy right it's a red flag right there
yeah
yeah okay so the son of man is also the
bridegroom
he's not only the judge but he's a
bridegroom he's both
okay but it's not just there there's
other places in scripture
john in his gospel tells us that the son
of man is the bridegroom as well
in john chapter 3 he has the interview
at night with nicodemus
and there he says in verse 13 no man is
ascended
up to heaven but he that came down from
heaven even the
son of man which is in heaven
[Music]
and then in verses 29 through 31
now the disciples of john have come to
him
they know that they figure that he'll be
somewhat bothered that people are
following jesus rather than john
but notice his response i used to wonder
what is this it didn't make sense until
i started
realizing the connection here in verse
29-31
john says this he that has the bride is
the bridegroom
but the friend of the bridegroom which
stands and hears him rejoices greatly
because of the bridegroom's voice
this my joy therefore is fulfilled he
must increase
i must decrease he that cometh from
above
is above all he that is of the earth is
earthly and speaketh of the earth
he that cometh from heaven is above all
so notice
the son of man is the one that came down
from heaven
but john is the one that is saying here
that the one who comes from above is
above all but he says it's the
bridegroom
the son of man is the bridegroom awesome
it's kind of nice to know that your
judge is also the one who wants to marry
you
right right right that's a good point it
gives you kind of a hope that the
verdict might come out well
right yeah he's also the advocate too
right
yes yes you're right he's a judge but
he's pleading for his bride yeah that's
awesome
but we it just keeps developing here so
there's there's the connections right
there in yellow right there
he that came down as the son of man but
he that came from above
that came down is also the bridegroom
all right now there are other places in
the bible though that make this
connection between
judgment and a wedding uh three chapters
earlier matthew 22
there's the parable of the wedding
garment and in that chapter
the king is putting on the wedding
festivities
and he's called people and when he calls
his eyes go into one particular person
he says
how did you come in here without a
wedding garment right
so there's a wedding going on but
there's also an investigation
you know did you fulfill the
requirements so that you're qualified to
be here on the wedding
so judgment and wedding go together
consistently in scripture
so we've got that people are gathered
there's an investigation
in that parable of the ten virgins where
we saw that the son of man is the
bridegroom
notice there that the bridegroom comes
in verse 10 and then the door is shut
and no matter how much you not to go in
with the bridegroom
at that point that the opportunity is so
again it's a judgment of
the sort of parallel the ark too
door was open on the ark for 120 years
but
when the rain started pound all you want
it's over
yeah there was a door but the door has
to be open
when the door was closed and there was a
there was a time period too it wasn't
like literally the doors shut and then
it started raining i mean there was
there was a time period there in between
that
where the door was shut and then the
actual judgment really the rain
came down later yep that's right so back
in daniel 7 9-13
it says that the son of man came with
the clouds of heaven and came to the
ancient of days and they brought him
near before him
so he's coming to serve as judge but if
you think about it
the son of man is coming on the clouds
for what to begin his wedding
but that should sound familiar because
doesn't the bible say something about
when he returns how does it how's he
supposed to come
but wait a minute think about it let's
put that here so it comes at the start
of the judgment at the start of his
wedding on clouds
but then there's many places but let's
say matthew 24 30
then shall appear the sign of the son of
man in heaven then shall the tribes of
the earth mourn and they shall see the
son of man coming in the
clouds of heaven with power great glory
so when his wedding begins he comes on
clouds
but when he comes again the second time
why is he coming
the wedding is over right yeah
interesting
yeah the son of man comes on clouds at
the end of the judgment at the
end of the wedding so clouds are the
beginning in the end the son of man's at
the beginning of the end
i'm coming to get married and now i'm
coming to get her
i mean this is exciting so it doesn't
start the judgment there
no this is actually marking the end of
the judgment
so the question is when the judgment
starts ah
okay well it starts when the wedding
started yeah
well look at that though yeah but it's
relevant for our time sufficient suffice
it to say that yeah we are in that
judgment power
okay so uh back in revelation 1 10 and
there's a this is it just gets so
beautiful i just love this
in revelation 1 10 john says i was in
the spirit on the lord's day and heard
behind me avoid a great voice as of a
trumpet
so we focused on the trumpet the voice
as of a trumpet being
pointing to the ten commandments the
basis of judgment
but notice also we didn't look at this
part it's on the lord's death
that actually is significant too if you
were to consider isaiah 58 13 and ask
yourself what is the lord's day
now depending what church you're in you
know you may say oh i know the lord's
day is it sunday
i used to i want to go to church they
would say you know happy lord's day
okay however if we let the bible just
explain itself
in isaiah 58 13 it says if you turn away
your foot from the sabbath
from doing your pleasure on my holy day
and call the sabbath the delight the
holy of lord
well the one speaking is the lord and he
says it's my day so the lord's day
according to scripture
is that's the sabbath it also says that
the seventh day is the sabbath of the
lord thy god
is there any parallel to i thought you
were going to pull us up
it's also a description of his second
coming right in the day of the lord
true actually this is a little bit of a
plan words
i would say they both have significance
probably the greater emphasis here is on
the actual sabbath but it is true this
is an unusual expression it doesn't come
across in english it does in grief
but it does seem to kind of combine the
ideas of the sabbath as the lord's day
but also yes the day of the lord
because the day of the lord is that
great judgment day the great day of the
lord god almighty
the sabbath though is intimately tied in
with that yes
but as far as this whole idea of
judgment and wedding
it's very important that we make a
connection with the sabbath here
and it's a beautiful connection right
here
so the lord says the sabbath but notice
the following about the sabbath
in exodus 20 verses 8 through 11 we find
the ten commandments and the sabbath
commandment says remember the sabbath
day to keep it holy for in six days the
lord get this word
made and it doesn't say created it says
made he is the creator but he made
heaven and earth
the sea and all but in the news and rest
of the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
they hound it
now don't forget he made right
isaiah 54 5. you've got to look this up
before i even show you on the screen
okay
pull that up on your screens you got it
you got to look at this
this is just where you just want to jump
out of your chair and go oh i get it
isaiah 54 5 45.
the piece of the verse says for thy
maker is
vine
wait a minute that maker is my husband
and it's the same word in hebrew
we're not stretching things wait a
minute
so if if our maker is our husband and we
know that he is he's our judge he wants
to marry us
but in the sabbath commandment alone it
refers to god
making heaven and earth what does that
suggest about
the sabbath itself
it reminds us yes he's our maker but it
reminds us also that he is our
so every week when we get the chance to
spin the sabbath rather than saying
oh does that mean i can't do this or i
can't do that or no
one's gonna be over it's a date yeah
it's a date
it's every week we get special time with
jesus yeah because you want to hang out
with you you know with the with your
spouse right
yeah i mean i remember hearing this
particular topic
brought up in a relationship um area and
i can remember the first time that i
kind of started thinking of this sabbath
really as this
this day that you get a chance to hang
out with your with your mate
right and and when you look at it like
that like let's say you didn't live in
the same area as your wife or whatever
and she was just like you know what i
only have next tuesday right are you
going to show up on wednesday you're
going to show up on friday
i'm going to show up on the day that
they're they're there to actually spend
that time with you and once i kind of
started to
understand it from that perspective i
was like of course god wants to spend
time with us i'm sure he's a busy god
right he has
all kinds of stuff in the universe to do
and here he's set aside
this day to say and you're certainly not
going to be looking at your watch
thinking oh when's it going to be over
i've really got to get to that lawn
right
or you know i really need to get back to
that project at work i mean
you want to spend time it's a privilege
it's joyful that's right
and so that just puts it it gives us the
right mindset
okay but notice this it goes even more
in exodus 31
it's just a few chapters after the ten
commandments matter of fact also
right before that unfortunate episode
with the golden calf
like two verses before it notice what it
says here the children of israel shall
keep the sabbath
to observe the sabbath throughout their
generations a perpetual covenant
it is a sign forever this is a beautiful
section if you look at verses 13 through
18 there
it actually mentions the sabbath seven
times you've got the whole chiasm thing
going on
but he says that the sabbath is a
perpetual covenant
but if it reminds us of our maker who is
our husband and it's a perpetual
covenant
god's idea of marriage is that it's what
yes yeah and so we're getting a taste
of that eternal marriage every week he's
like you're getting a glimpse of it
it should be getting better better every
week because does it make sense that he
has this parallel in the wedding right
that you're supposed to be joined
together
forever right i tell my wife all the
time when we get to heaven sorry
you're you're stuck with me sweetheart
you know like we're not
you're breaking apart i know i know you
know this is a whole different
theological topic
but um i i just think that god is is
when he says something in the old
testament like that and he says this is
a perpetual covenant
that that was meant to last throughout
the end of time you know
so death do you depart though but we're
not gonna die right
yeah i mean i don't believe that you
coming in
to have it and the angel is going to
give you a divorce paper right
yeah right he's like okay sorry i mean
yeah speaking of divorce look at what
god says about it and again
this helps us put the right perspective
if you have malachi 2 verses 14-16
god is making a case against his people
they've been unfaithful and he says the
lord has been witness between thee and
the wife of thy youth
against whom thou hast dealt
treacherously yet she is thy companion
and the wife
of thy covenant for the lord the god of
israel seth that he hateth putting away
and he hates divorce now depending what
your background is you could look at
that and say oh boy i feel like
you know things didn't work out you know
i had some unfortunate episode in the
past
i've gone through divorce and that seems
like he's condemning you
but if you look at it no no look at the
other way around he's saying i hate
divorce because i can't
bear the thought of letting you go and
says it breaks my heart when you get
divorced
on earth because that is marring
the picture of how i am to you he says
i've never put you away
you have the choice of walking away from
me but he says i won't do that to you
unless you just
leave and so actually it's a it's a
great picture of hope
and it's interesting too in the garden
of eden there were two institutions
what were the two institutions that were
instituted in the garden of eden the
sabbath
it's no coincidence they're twin
institutions
one informs the other they're covenants
and they're both
ever lasting covenants
whoa so yeah i just want to make a
comment
that's why it's so important about when
are you gonna get married
it's not like just jump in i mean it's
so quick right i mean
that's what you have about time to like
to prepare
i mean just to make sure that the person
you're gonna get married is
forever and you know what that helps us
understand then we said that
the judgment is the wedding but the
wedding is the judgment during this time
that's going on now if we're in the
judgment hour we're in the wedding hour
but it's taking some time what do you
think god's doing
have you ever thought of the judgment as
kind of like courtship
he's investigating you see okay let's
gather the evidence
are you going to be faithful to me
forever because that's the only one i'm
going to take to heaven
and he's giving us every chance and if
we're giving evidence that now we're
holding on to this element of the world
or that element he says i'm going to
bring some judgments on you to iron that
out
get that out of you so that i can bring
you to heaven that's awesome
judgment does a beautiful thing yeah you
know the testing
time is really like you know somebody's
integrity
when no one's watching that's the true
that's the true message you know if if
you actually
you know stay true to your bride when no
one else
is going to know anything you know and i
think that that's that's what god is
doing he's preparing his people now
because we can't see him really we can
you know
we can see him in our mind's eye but not
physically at this stage yet and i think
this is the this is the courtship
uh this is probably in your book and i
think i already knew it before
scotty and and all that as i've i used
to listen to somebody who used to talk
about this kind of stuff
um it's like what is he doing one of
those things he is doing
the languages in john 14 where he's
preparing a place
yes and that's what the groom
did you know before he received his
bride as he went and prepared a place at
his father's house
yes before he you know went and received
his bride and brought her back
you know what's exciting there it is
absolutely true that's that was true
like if you just looked at how the
hebrews would do things but the reason
he said that
it's not because they did it they were
doing it because they knew from a bowl
that's how god does it
jesus says i'm going to prepare a place
for you he's going to his father's house
there's many mansions but it literally
it means dwellings and that's not
saying oh is it going to be a shack as
opposed to a mansion the old meeting for
mansion is a dwelling place that's all
it means
but we're going to dwell where god
dwells and his dwelling place is the
sanctuary
but that's where the judgment takes
place that's where the marriage takes
place he says i'm building
an addition as it were onto the heavenly
sanctuary so that you can come live
where
the home is it's kind of interesting
today also in the sanctuary we talk
as inside the sanctuary as the ten
commandments
and there's the judgment i mean with
what kind of law you know because when
you go with the judgment
i mean it has to be a lot right i mean
you broke the law
but if you break down that law what is
it in its simplistic form right it's a
relationship
it's a you know if i love my wife i'm
not gonna cheat on her if i
if i'm not gonna kill her i'm not gonna
steal from her i'm not gonna you know
what i mean these are relationships from
man's perspective
and then also if if i'm in love with god
why would i have another god
you know so it's our relationship with
god and the interesting thing about the
ten commandments
when you read in hebrew they're um like
we read in english like thou shalt not
this that sounds like a command
but in hebrew that that's not written
that it's written as just statements of
fact
you're not going to do this yeah you're
not going to do that it's a promise
it's exactly what it is in fact they're
called the ten words and the words in
the bible
actually many times especially in modern
translations really are translated as
promises
many times statements the fact that god
says it's so it's true it's a promise
i'm guaranteeing that you won't have
other gods you won't cheat on your wife
you're not going to murder because
you're mine
you become one with me and this is
transcript of my character and it's
gonna be a transcript of yours
that's why god promises he will ride it
upon our hearts
you're jumping in yeah
you said you'll become one made me think
of in genesis when i said the
the two will become one it says yes when
it says that they'll leave their father
and mother and it made me think when
jesus said
if you love your father and mother or
whatever more than me then you're not
fit for the kingdom it's like same word
it's kind of like a parallel man you
start seeing
once you have this like this lens on you
begin seeing the marriage motif
from genesis to revelation because right
there in genesis 2
well genesis 1 i guess but genesis 2
were they supposed to come together
all the way into the last chapter of
revelation it's beautiful
but yeah the getting back to the sabbath
though it's god's pledge of marital
fidelity to his people
so again rather than saying oh man i
can't be whatever
yeah no this is his promise i'm going to
be faithful forever
and if you'll allow me i'm going to get
you to the point where you're faithful
so the key is here that john received
the revelation
on the lord's day he received it on
sabbath hinting
to somebody who's really attuned to
scripture that wait a minute that's
god's day that points to
that he wants to marry us it sets up the
marriage name yet again in revelation
chapter one
right and so instead of looking at all
these national inquiry sensational
things about beasts and
you know all these crazy unfounded ideas
about what it's about
no we have to go with the mindset of a
bride and then
everything in the book comes into right
focus
it's really fascinating okay
one last thing revelation 1 it's the
very first phrase it says it's the
revelation of jesus christ
the revealing of yes it reveals who
jesus
really is what what his relationship is
with us
and it does talk all about his character
but there's something about it
just the other day i got to thinking
about this not that way
i wonder could it be it turns out in
leviticus
chapter 18 verses 6 through 19. this
whole litany of verses but they all say
you are not to uncover this person's
nakedness and go into them you're not to
uncover this person's
goodness you know it's only between the
man and his wife
and i thought i wonder in the greek
translation
the of the hebrew there is the word
there for uncover
perhaps the same as revelation here
and guess what it so when he says that
the revelation of jesus christ
it's nothing dirty but rather it's
saying if you come with the mindset of
looking at this as a marriage he says
then for that kind of person i'm going
to reveal myself i'm going to show you
all that i am sorry but if you're not if
you're not my bride you'll never
understand it
and so it's like ah even there in the
opening words
it hints at marriage that coming
together
it's like the honeymoon it's a beautiful
thing
okay now when is it appropriate to
become intimate well
after marriage right on your mind that's
right and so if that's
that's right there again we've kind of
discussed that many times on this
show um where we talk about the the
actual
you know act the same act can be done
inside and outside of marriage and one
way will destroy you and one way will
actually edify you
and and build you up and it's amazing to
me it's like you're doing the same thing
but just the context of the the way that
it is done
makes all the difference in the world
and if if you're doing it outside of
marriage then really what it comes down
to is selfishness you're just
you're getting a few moments where it
feels good so what you're doing is
gratifying
your flesh but god's plan is to say no
we're going to become one flesh not that
we'll become god but we'll have his
character
and then we're not doing anything
selfish which just we're in perfect
harmony
and that's that's the big difference
it's awesome yeah
so what time is it hand it should be
obvious the time that's at hand in the
book of revelation is what
no well yeah now but i mean judgment but
it's the god's willing yeah the marriage
it's exactly right
god's marriage and that's what the
judgment is
we can look at the judgment at positive
light
look at what paul says about marriage he
says for this cause this is ephesians 5
verses 31 and 32
for this cause shall a man leave his
father and mother and shall be joined
unto his wife and they too shall be one
flesh
this is a great mystery but i speak
concerning christ in the church
it's like he's telling us that marriage
is about how christ relates to the
church
is it any great surprise that the climax
of the bible is going to be about okay
now we're going to put all the pieces
together
and it's going to end when the marriage
is um
well consummated the vows are exchanged
it says now you're mine forever
i believe after and then that's why they
get hints later on in revelations it
calls the marriage supper of the lamb
you know celebrating the wedding that's
she's made herself ready
i mean there's so many amazing parallels
i i don't know if you're going to get to
this but the whole
wedding supper at the end right exactly
what we do in our wedding
cultures today i mean we have a feast
after
the marriage and the bride the groom
kiss and you know they run out and
we all celebrate that that's exactly
what's going to happen in heaven
that is that is a good pair there are
some other things where we kind of get
it backwards like
in in western culture anyways the focal
point of the wedding
everyone rises and looks at who the
bride but in scripture
behold the bride groom cometh yeah so
there's a few there's a few differences
there too
but yes that is absolutely true about
the wedding supper in our mail driven
world that wouldn't go over well
i wonder though if kind of like the
heavenly hosts are looking like there's
the people that
there's this bride you know i wonder if
their attention might be kind of on us
oh i mean they are they are riveted
there and that's why they're excited in
revelation 19.
she's made herself ready they are
excited so there is a focus there
but ultimately our focus should be on
that's right i don't mean the earthly
bride
but the the heavenly bragger jesus yeah
okay so earthly marriage illustrates
christ's relations to his church
now you had mentioned earlier about
where it talks about in hebrews there
why would jesus be called the son of man
well
there's a couple places but in hebrews
chapter 4
verses 14 and 15 matter of fact i don't
know do you want to do you want to read
that verse for us there mikey
so hebrews 4 15 says for we do not have
a high priest we
who cannot sympathize with our weakness
but was in all points tempted
as we are yet without sin let us
therefore come boldly to the throne of
grace
that we may obtain mercy and find grace
to help
in time of need so notice he knows what
it's like to be tempted
so he doesn't this look sin displeases
him and he cannot tolerate it
but it rather than saying he's looking
with the condemning eyes like it breaks
his heart when he sees that
and so he sympathizes though because he
says i know what it's like to be tempted
i had those 40 days in the wilderness
the devil if the devil to ever tempted
anybody was jesus
but he says you know what i overcame
and i love you so much i am going to
give you that ability to do it if you
will let me
that's how much he loves us you know
this is this is kind of a strange thing
but
um you're married right you guys are
married
you're married you'll find this out
someday that
there are some things that my wife feels
she doesn't even have to say anything to
me
and then all of a sudden we'll like i'll
say the same thing or i'll feel the same
thing
and it's just that close connection that
you have
i mean it just happened to me yesterday
um i was sitting there literally i
moved all my stuff out of my house and i
was literally laying in bed and i was
thinking about how to move a particular
mirror in my house
and i was thinking if i put my my
mattress in the car i can put the mirror
in between the mattress
and i didn't say anything i just
literally thought it in my head
and my wife goes hey you know how we can
move that
mirror you can put it in between your
mattresses and i was just like are you
kidding me
did i say that out loud but that's kind
of like what
what jesus is telling us right here i
mean he's literally saying listen
i went through this i know what it's
like i can help you through this i feel
with
what what you are experiencing and i'm
able to help you in that time of need
right and he invites us to come bully we
don't need to be thinking well
oh i really made a mess of things do i
dare come to him he says please come to
me
you know if you'll come to me i'm not
ready to throw the book at you i'm ready
to clean you off and
let's sort this out and so he says that
you will obtain mercy
and grace there's two different things
mercy is where okay i won't hold it
against you grace is where i'm going to
give you the power to overcome it
he says i'm going to give you both
become bolder what if esther never went
to the king you know
exactly i think he's actually alluding
to it right here and notice it's the
throne of grace
where he also does judgment but he says
it's also where i'm going to give you
the ability to
to stand strong in the gentleman
in hebrews chapter two verily he took
not on him the nature of angels but he
took on him the seed of abraham
wherefore in all things that behooved
him to be made like unto his brethren
that he might be i love us a merciful
and faithful high priest
high priest is the judge and the
bridegroom as well in things pertaining
to god
to make reconciliation for the sins of
the people for in that he himself
hath suffered being tempted he is able
to
sucker them that are tempted and and
tell us what the word
sucker means that means that he is able
to
like if you're if you're a little child
then you get a boo-boo what your mother
does
gives you a hug and makes you feel
better that's
supper or sucker that's what a band-aid
is
yeah so the son of this is this is so
neat though
when jesus came 2000 years ago he took
on
our nature which is nothing to brag
about but he took his bride's neighbor
brides nature so that he could
rightfully become one flesh with her
the good news is he didn't stay like i
mean he's he knows what it's like
and so he says okay i have identified
with you but the news gets better
because now let's look at the other way
around peter says in second peter one
verse
four that there are exceeding great and
precious promises that are given to us
that by these ye might be partakers of
the divine nature now some would stretch
that to mean we become god that's not
correct
but he says when you come to heaven yes
i'm preparing you will have that
character of god
the one that's in the ten commandments
having escaped the corruption that is in
the world through lust in other words
having gotten victory over sin
by his grace so jesus took our nature to
become one flesh
but if that's where it stayed then we'd
say oh boy is that it he says no no
but having done that he says now i am
going to lift you up so you can have my
divine nature
and so that's the kind of nature that we
want to share we will wave one flesh
having
that nature the character of god
this is the kind of bridegroom i want
and this
you couldn't ask for a better judge
this is the way to study revelation man
this is awesome
i'm really inspired and
i'm enjoying this yeah it's not doom and
gloom
like everybody paints this you know like
scary picture of it
when it's like you really get to the
bottom of it it's like wow this is this
is really a love story
that's exactly what it is that is
exactly what it is and once
once you get that then all the other
things all the different doctrines you
can see in
revelation they make more sense they are
all true
but you can approach them as well it
says this you better do it or not
or you can approach it say let's lay a
foundation of god his
great plan is to redeem mankind to marry
them and then with that mindset all the
other doctrines take on
this whole new beauty to them it's about
his love
so what's jesus doing now in the
judgment well as the son of man he's
investigating
his prospective bride's character and
earth we call that
courtship yeah that's true
is this person somebody that i want to
be with my whole life i mean that's what
you're essentially doing when you're
dating
you're investigating them you're you
know you're you're
i've always heard the best way to um to
make sure that that's the person you
want to be with is go camping
if you can set up a tent together and
you can you know cook and everything
like that and the stuff goes well now if
you're not married you should set up two
tins but
um that's a good way to to see what kind
of character this person is all about
because camping can sometimes be
stressful and that is just something
interesting
there is a judgment going on right now
but what he's doing is only those who
have
professed to love jesus are the ones
being investigated right now
later revelation speaks about those who
have always rejected you and so the
judgment is focused on his bride
and so but he wants to say anybody can
say oh
sure you know in the heat of the moment
i'll say yes
but you know time reveals a lot of
things he says let's let's let time
linger here let's see is that a hollow
profession or is there
something to it is it genuine now for
all of us because we've all
indulged in sin he says i there's gonna
be
we have to clean you up nobody's ready
the moment they say yes it's not an
instantaneous thing
and so he administers the necessary
judgments that's all part of the wedding
he said i minister those judgments
because he's not going to change but he
says you need to
and in a marriage you make little
sacrifices you'll put the toilet paper
on this way or whatever because it
pleases her or something right
so you want to do you know we want to
please jesus and
and it doesn't it's not like a burden
you're just like oh it makes her happy
i'll do that
i also like the idea that you brought up
with with with there being a time to
kind of test that
and rather than looking at it like what
is god doing why is he waiting
you know what i mean maybe maybe he's
waiting to see what we're like
how are we going to handle this how are
we going to how is this going to play
out
for us and if it's taking so long and
long one person lives and they die
another generation
maybe it's because we just haven't
learned to surrender as a bride yet
but when that finally takes place let's
say okay now
she's ready what happens in a
disappointment and i think that's why
when you study kind of church history
and there was the great disappointment
right how many people signed up
sold their houses sold their businesses
everybody's like yeah we're going to
heaven jesus is coming soon right
and then i'll say he doesn't come how
many of those people went
and see that that was a judgment of
sorts where it's like okay
i can see that those those were hollow
but there was a faithful few and in the
revelation there's
tribulation great tribulation are you
going to stand true to the end you know
that's right so he's refining her
character right there
so the judgment of the wedding they're
one and the same we shouldn't be afraid
of a wedding
no we should be looking forward to it
but there is some work and you know and
sometimes in preparing for a wedding
there can be some frustrating things you
know because it you know
things aren't going quite according to
plan or whatever but you still you don't
just say oh well
i don't want to go to the wedding no you
say i want to power through this so that
i can get to the wedding
right okay so that's the mindset i have
a comment
a lot of christians they believe the
judgment is going to be
after the wedding and the thing is kind
of like
so what is going to be the judgment it's
going to be
like he's going to take you to heaven
and he's going to go all the way through
it like okay you did wrong now you go
back to the
hell did you i don't know if you heard
that one but
it's a lot of christians they believe
that well and but see that's just like
what keith had mentioned about the in
john 14.
he says i'm going to prepare a place for
you and
then i will come to receive you unto
myself or like when he talks about to
the
to the goats that are on his left and
then he speaks to the sheep that are on
his right
he says you know enter into the joy
of my presence you don't enter if you've
already been there
so yeah there is no point and you can't
go to be with jesus until the wedding is
over
if we went to heaven like right now on
the judgment sometime later
that means that we're going before the
marriage has taken place
interesting and then it would be like
it's a sad thought but that would be to
make jesus
that would be adultery yeah that's deep
fornication yeah that's deep
yeah because if you know and another
topic about what
if you die you go to heaven and they say
okay the judgment
time i said okay scotty uh you need to
go back
to the right no wait i don't want to
leave yeah
once again this whole wedding idea helps
us to understand certain truths and what
is the correct view
because they will be consistent and this
this lens helps everything to be
internally consistent otherwise you
start running into things that don't
quite
jump and i think god in his mercy he
gives us things that are tangible to us
to understand
like if you just understand how jesus
operated he was walking around going oh
wow we live in an agricultural society
so
here's what a seed does here's what
happens when you plant this thing right
and people were like oh yeah i get that
i'm
i'm a farmer you know but here is a
language that we can understand we can
we can see these complex things that are
happening are transpiring right now in
the wake of time and then it's a way for
us to go oh yeah okay well i understand
this
this happens in a wedding and now this
is what's really happening over here
these different judgments that take
place they prepare us to be one flesh
with him
but the bible also calls the day of
judgment the day of atonement and helps
us understand
atonement is at one minute like at one
flesh
that's we are to become one that's
that's what's going on right there
so when when the bride's character is
perfectly refined when god is finished
doing his judgment on us
and he's got us ready she is finally one
flesh with him
the wedding is then complete and if
if if you've got all the preparations in
place for your wedding right
you say okay we've got everybody lined
up everybody's been invited
uh we've got the one who's going to
exchange the values for us and
everything
once that's all there then you waste no
time here it's like let's just
get it done right yeah well when he is
done with his
wedding or we might call it the
courtship phase of the wedding right
there
he's going to come to claim her as his
own that's right the second coming
that's right so yeah that's the that's
the second coming right there so
that's uh that's what i had for today so
wow is that all in this book the wedding
yes i want to read this one honestly
honestly
this is such a neat topic to be able to
understand
now what's going on now and and so we
we've got to put a link you have lots of
these
yes like like um if you guys want to
read more in-depth i mean obviously
we're
able to just sort of brush stroke give
you the bullet points here
but if you really want to go and deep
into this topic
and begin to see god as this
relationship this marriage covenant that
happens
um great book uh check this out and
we'll put a link in the description
where you can actually buy these
and get a hold of them but um yeah
for those of you who are interested
we're going to do a giveaway
of scott's books we'll give away one of
the wedding and we'll give away one of
the stand so go to our website little
light studios
dot tv slash free offer and
the link will be in the description
below and maybe you can be a recipient
of one of these
books thank you guys for watching if you
guys were blessed
like share comment um if you want to see
more content from from scott do you have
a youtube channel or anything
uh yeah that's been working on it
when this airs you can go there yes
there you go there you go so we'll uh
we'll hopefully put a link in the
description where you can actually see
more content from scott but
thank you guys for watching and we'll
catch you on the next one
[Music]
you